Hey everybody, welcome to
the content video going
over section 4.3, functions
with multiple parameters.
Parameters are just
another word for arguments
when it comes to defining a function.
So this is actually a pretty straightforward
and short section. Basically,
when you create a custom function,
you can have as many or as few
arguments as you want. So this
example right here they've created a
function called maximum which works
exactly the same as the max function.
Value one, value two, value three
just returns the biggest one of all
of those. So you can see they call
it here with three arguments. They've
defined it with three arguments
and then we'll go through kind of
coding this but we could add in more
or less arguments just depending
on how we're feeling that day. So
let's jump over to our code space.
So remember a function
requires four things.
A name so we'll call this
let's call it biggest. It's
a little bit different than
the built-in maximum function
biggest and then we need
argument so let's take 4
arg1, arg2, arg3, and arg4 and then
we'll say biggest equals max of arg1
r2, r3, arg4.
And the last thing we need
after our main body of
code is the return statement,
so we'll return biggest.
And I did that thing again where I
named the variable the same as the
function. I think it's fine in this
case, so we'll leave it. Anyways,
let's call this function. Let's say
large boy equals biggest of 1, 5,
45, and 1,009. That's
a lot more than 1,009.
Let's print out large boy.
There he is.
We would never have guessed that.
And let's run it one
more time. this time with
negative 1, negative
whatever number that is.
45 is our biggest. Okay, so
this is where it gets really
kind of interesting. So I
could also add r5 on here,
right? But check out what
happens when I run my code now.
We are missing an argument when
we call the function. So if
I was to add another argument,
I kind of need to add in more
numbers when I call the
function so that my code doesn't
break so oh weird 35 definitely
isn't the biggest year 90s you
just break something in python huh
oh it's because here's why it's
it is broken it's because we're
not using arg5 in our function
right so this is a good teaching
moment for you guys while you're
watching me figure this out live
arg5 is something that is required
for us to call the function but
then we're not actually returning
the max of all the numbers. We're
only looking at them up to arg4.
So if we threw arg5 in here, then
our code should be fixed. All
right, so that's kind of all I
wanted you guys to know for this
content video is that you can have
as many arguments as possible as
you want in a custom function
definition. So thank you for watching